each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hello everybody welcome good Monday
morning to everybody my name is Tom ball
and it's my great pleasure to welcome
doma babak back to Microsoft Research he
was an intern with us previously and
worked with Ma da Mousa Vavi and myself
for a little bit he was an MSR graduate
fellow recipient and fellowship
recipient and he got his PhD with Alan
who at the University of British
Columbia since then he's been in
industry for a little bit and more
recently a research scientist at UC
Berkeley and he's been working on
security and program analysis and we're
going to hear more about that today
thanks Tom so uh thanks for that great
introduction good morning everyone it
has been a while since I visited emma
Starr the last time I think the last
time I was here was like three or four
years ago yeah perhaps so so today I'm
going to talk a little bit about
grammatical inference and its
applications to security and program
analysis so this is the work that I've
been mostly doing during last year year
and a half with a number of
collaborators at Berkeley so you can see
grammatical inference at the high level
as a set of machine learning techniques
that try to infer a formal language
either context-free or a regular or
something like that and you know I'm
going to talk about this more this is
just so that you know what I'm talking
about at this point to motivate the work
I'm going to start with some numbers
first so over the last decade we've been
witnessing a deluge of malware so
according to some statistics antivirus
companies are receiving over 60,000
samples per day nowadays and if you
summed it up it's around 20 million year
and one of the main attack vectors that
that malware exploits our software flaws
not surprisingly and for instance only
last year in 2010 we saw over 4,000
medium and high severity vulnerabilities
in coma boner
disclosures a database and all several
hundred low severity ones and this is
probably just a drop in the sea of CDs
that haven't been disclosed or were just
pitched without without filing CB so uh
well i think that the state of the art
is not surprising considering how
complicated software systems are and
it's can said in his talk probably
software systems are the most
complicated systems that people develop
nowadays and so the process of designing
software systems is kind of like a two
component process where in one part
we're adding new features and the other
part we are finding and removing bugs
and fixing security issues and this
second part tends to be usually around
fifty percent of the effort sometimes
much more and I looked at some
statistics for instance of the relative
sizes of Windows test and development
teams and it seems that the test test
team is somewhat larger so this seems to
be correct statistic so effectively the
complexity of the systems that we can
develop at least in part is limited but
by what we can verify to be correct and
it's a cure and so just recently for
instance I talked to some people from
Lockheed Martin and they said that
they're really limited in the systems
that they are developing by what they
can test and verify so that really seems
to be a limiting factor and so what
happens if you actually allow these
systems due to be kind of partially
faulty or partially insecure well the
cost of failures can be really
tremendous especially security-related
failures so according to some statistics
Code Red which was essentially which
exploited an unchecked buffer in ms is
server incurred over two billion dollars
in damages so now if you compare that
for instance to the cost of bugs in
hardware industry it's roughly the same
order of magnitude and so it seems that
so traditionally we consider that we
believe that verification was especially
sex
test fill in the verification in
hardware industry exactly because these
bugs can be so expensive but it seems
that we have the same exactly the same
thing happening in software industry and
so well a lot of work has been done on
improving the state of the art on
verification automated testing on
various approaches to improve security
and automation has been kind of like the
core aspect of many of those approaches
and I think that the community has
definitely made a huge progress and
especially our automating reasoning for
instance like you know smt has made a
huge has had a huge impact on on
verification and automated testing but
one aspect that that still is kind of a
problematic is inductive reasoning so it
seems that when it comes to inductive
reasoning we still have a long way to go
and thinking about this is started
looking into a set of techniques that
are called inductive grammatical
inference which is as I said before a
class of machine learning techniques
that learn formal language and then
there are several basic flavors of
grammatical inference so for instance
you can learn from observed behavior and
then generalize from that behavior and
construct you know say a state machine
or grammar or you can learn
interactively by probing a black box or
say a gray box and then go the mode in
which you're learning and then listening
to the responses in that way you know
learning your grammar so this class of
approaches was very intensively studied
in the 90s and then somehow a large
parts of the machine learning community
figured out that for many of their
applications they can actually also use
less expensive statistical approaches so
that became kind of the focus of most of
the research but still there is small
part of community that continued
research along the grammatical inference
in in the grammatical infinite direction
so some of the strengths of GI
grammatical inference is that it's very
effective at inferring structure so
often when you need to understand the
structure of your problem then GI is the
way to go and also another strength is
that it's inherently inductive reasoning
but the problem is that it can often
overgeneralize so if you don't have
negative counter examples that are going
to that you were going to use for
refining then there's always real danger
for generalizing it for instance if you
have only positive examples you always
can infer trivially single state state
machine is going to accept everything
but that's not what you actually want
and so GI has many applications and I'm
going to talk today about several
applications that I've studied and also
a little bit about some possible
applications that I'm planning to study
in the in the future so the first and
probably the most obvious application is
reverse engineering for instance if you
have you know a proprietary or
classified protocol and you want to
figure out what the protocol does then
GI is kind of a good way to go about
that and I'm going to talk in the first
part of the talk about inference of
unknown proprietary protocols and I'll
describe how one could do that so
another possible application is for
program abstraction and that's something
that I'm going to talk in the second
part of the talk so you can you can use
G I to infer kind of stateful
abstractions of your program either you
know abstraction of interfaces or
abstraction of certain modules or
abstractions of the whole program and
then use those abstractions in various
ways and also another possibility is to
infer abstractions of behavior for
instance for malware you're really
interested in what what malware does and
now the idea is to try to infer kind of
models stateful models of that of that
behavior and so that that's something
that I'm going to be discussing the
third part of the talk other possible
applications are did something actually
that that I'm working on these days is
inference of invariants so can you how
can you use G I to infer interface
invariants or for instance queue
invariance if you're if you're analyzing
say distributed systems with unbounded
queues then one of the critical parts of
the analysis is figuring out what the
queue invariants are because once when
you know that you invariance essentially
especially if the system has certain
properties then
analysis becomes a much simpler and
tractable also other possible
applications are in synthesis for
instance there was there is a seminal
paper by a beer man i think in 79 who
showed that the grammatical inference
can be used to infer kind of programs
from essentially from traces it he
focused his research on inference of
incomplete state machines but he and he
proposed an algorithm for kind of for
for doing this inference so uh this
figure just illustrates the you know how
grammatical inference works at a very
high level so as I said one possible
flavor of GI is that you know you
observe some traffic between our two
effectively black boxes you know they
exchanged messages sequences of messages
and then you observe that traffic and
then you learn grammar of that of that
protocol and another possible approach
is a proactive approach where you keep
sending sequences of messages and you
listening to responses and then learn
the state machine that way so this is
the outline of the talk so in the first
part I'm going to be talking about
protocol inference that this was more or
less warm up project for the student
that I'm working with and I'm going to
use between it to just introduce the
basic concepts and to kind of explain
how this inference works for instance in
the protocol setting and then in the
second part i'm going to show how this
protocol inference could be combined
with program analysis to guide state
space exploration so I named that
approach maze or model inference
assisted con colic execution and just
presented it last week at usenix
security and then in the third part I'm
going to present something slightly
different so this is more focused on
inferring structure and inferring kind
of abstractions of behavior of malgor
and then I'm going to show how you can
use GI there to kind of detect malware
and I'm going to present some some
results on that so to start with with
protocol inference in particular we we
focused on on on Bodmin protocols so
those protocols are essentially
proprietary protocols and
way these botnets work is that you know
they infect potentially large number of
machines some of these botnets infect
hundreds of thousands of machines and
they're fairly complicated distributed
systems so you have like both both
individual bots on clients and their
clients in this whole distributed system
and then you have servers that kind of
support this whole network and and and
they serve various purposes so for
instance in the mega the botnet command
and control protocol so you have clients
in one side and they have three types
actually have more types of servers but
three types are like really important so
you have like the master server which
which is used to to send commands to to
individual boards so you can you know
send them commands to kind of like a
sense spam you can send them commands to
kind of like start eavesdropping on the
on the infected machine or you know all
kinds of comments you essentially can
control the individual boards and then
they have also so which one was this one
oh this one was the essence this one was
the template server so they have
template servers that kind of serve
templates and the way these Princeton
spamming botnets work is that they have
they keep getting fresh templates on a
daily basis and then they are kind of
individualized these templates so that
they increase the chances of people
clicking on them and then they start
spamming around and know if your control
if you're controlling say you know
hundreds of thousands of machines you
can really send like it's like a really
huge amounts of spam through that botnet
and people are actually play a paying a
lot for for that service and then there
is also the third type of the server
called just smtp server that's kind of
like test server so each boat sends a
message an email to that server and then
if it gets response that means that it
can successfully send spam so it's kind
of like more or less a testing server
but it plays very important role in the
whole protocol is as I will show later
and then there's some other server
servers as well so for instance there is
an update server you know these buttons
have automatic distributed updates you
know infrastructure so they're fairly
complicated so now the problem that we
want to solve we want to figure out how
this protocol works so that we can you
know figure out potentially how to
defeat or how to kind of detect such
such infection on a corporate network or
academic Network so how would we go
about this well we can apply the
classical the classic England's Elstar
algorithm and I can't really go into all
the details but I want to give you kind
of just an impression of how how it
works at a higher level so here we have
a stage machine that we want to infer so
it's an unknown state machine and we
let's assume that we know the input
alphabet Sigma I and the output alphabet
of that state machine so the way how
I'll start works is that it constructs a
table also called an observation table
and then fills up all the rows and
columns and then when it's done it just
reads off the states and transitions
from the table so what we have here is
that the this part of the table stores
contains all the outputs meaning
responses from the black box that we are
kind of probing and then the first row
contains the suffixes and then the first
column contains the prefixes of inputs
and the way you generate input is that
you combine the prefix with the suffix
and that's how you get a sequence of
messages you get the query and then you
send that query to the to the black box
that you're a state machine you're
trying to learn you're listening to the
response and then you store the response
in the in the observation table so for
example here we start with epsilon and
then concatenate it with a and so we get
string a that is the input and then the
response here is why and so we store
that in the table we always store only
the suffix of the response that's equal
to the length of
of the string in the first row so in
this case we store only a single symbol
so repeat the same thing with other
edges so with B and C and so at this
point we learn what we call a state
distinguishing vector so this is kind of
like a signature of a state and then we
extend the symbol in the in the first
row epsilon with all the symbols in the
input alphabet and so now we concatenate
this symbol the prefix with the suffix
so we get a a input we execute that on
the stage machine so we get the response
YY but then we store only the suffix y
to the table so you repeat the same
thing with a B and HC and now we repeat
the same thing for other sequences and
now you can see that the first state
distinguished vector is already a
present in the upper half of the table
which which essentially contains unique
state distinguishing vectors for every
state so we don't need to move it up
there but the second vector doesn't have
representative in the upper part of the
table so effectively it represents a new
state so we move it up there and then
the same for the third one at this point
we have effectively identified all three
states but then we still don't know all
the transitions so we take the the
sequences from the that represents
states and append the all the symbols
from the input alphabet getting
sequences like be a BB and so on we got
along with three states but actually an
algorithm
yes right okay right so yeah we know
that but the algorithm is proceeding
I've got just with the same yes what
you're describing now is just look work
so now we essentially concatenate for
instance this part the prefix which
suffixes and they fill up the table and
at this point you know when we check all
the state distinguishing vectors we see
that they all have representatives in
the upper part and so at this point the
algorithm makes conjecture that this is
the state machine implemented by by the
black box and so it reads solved the
states from the upper half and
transitions from the lower half of the
table and at this point we say that the
table is closed and we've essentially
learn the conjecture rather than a full
model so now the problem is how do you
check that the state machine is really
what the black box actually implements
and their various approaches to do that
so one possibility is to generate so
called sampling queries and then you can
if you generate sufficient a number of
these sampling queries then you can
grantee that the inferred state machine
is correct with some probability and
with some confidence another possible
approach is that you can also do
something that's called a black box
model checking so you bound it black box
model checking so you can generate the
distinguishing sequence up to a certain
depth of the state machine and then
check that what you've inferred is
really what does the black box
implements so this all looks great but
unfortunately doesn't really work in
practice and there are several reasons
for that so first the the state space is
really too large in practical
applications so if you have say 32-bit
message then the number of 32-bit kind
of like packet size you know that some
server receives or sends then the number
of messages that you need to consider is
really large and l star is not going to
scale to that furthermore there are some
other problems in in the in the context
of inferring botnet protocols so these
these botnets are fairly large and so
and
also they're kind of owners they have a
lot of capability to inspect what's
going on in the network so you know if
they figure out that you're kind of like
playing with their botnet they can
trigger a denial of service attack on
the source of that kind of air traffic
so to experiment with with these botnets
we essentially had to use store which is
like network under anonymizer and so it
anonymize 'as all the traffic so that
the receiver can figure out where the
traffic is coming from so that is kind
of a nice solution but unfortunately
introduces a lot of delay so on average
we had delay of about 6.8 seconds per
every message that we sent and so it
turns out that you need something like
four and a half days to infer 17 state
protocol which is not really acceptable
in practice it also there are some other
problems like dealing with decryption
compression and non determinism and I'm
not going to talk about those today
there's been some prior work that we
build upon for dealing with encryption
and compression the alphabet I'll get to
that again today so edit a little
problem yes yes I so that were right so
at this point I'm just saying that if
you treat the packets as their scent is
alphabet that's not going to scale and
so now I'm going to get to the part
where I'm going to explain how to deal
with alphabet so as I mentioned its
computational II feel in fur you know
these protocols over the you know of the
packets that are actually sent over the
network because simply because the state
space is too large so the approach that
we took in this particular work and
later we have we've changed it a little
bit is that we first observe
communication between the client and the
server in this case it was a
communication between a boat and I'm
those servers that I mentioned earlier
and so we find the set of input messages
and set of out of messages alternatives
are those sent from the server back to
the boat to individual boats and then
studying those we came up with to
abstraction functions so one is the
input message obstruction function
is that would message abstraction
function that take these network packets
and then object abstract them into
abstract alphabets called Sigma I and
Sigma 0 and so once when you write these
abstraction functions manually then the
abstraction is of course automatic and
it takes some effort it's a bit tedious
to come up with these with good
abstraction functions because the state
machine that you infer essentially
depends on how well this abstraction
functions are are working so it's a bit
tedious but it doesn't actually take
that much time and we also use some
prior work for reverse engineering of
message formats to to help us with that
and then in the later work in this what
I'm going to present in second part of
the paper we actually figure out how to
do the input message abstraction
automatically but we still require the
output message abstraction function to
be provided and I'm going to talk about
it later so now what's happening is that
you know you have the inference engine
in some you know that that has inferred
some states so far and then it starts
sending you know it keeps sending these
sequences / of abstract input messages
and then we have a script that actually
does concretization and also take it has
to take care about some other aspects so
for instance that it keeps the session
alive that it has the right session
identifier so there is some there's some
details there that i'm going to abstract
away but essentially what it does it
really concrete eyeses the messages from
this abstract alphabet to concrete
alphabet and sub I so we send these
sequences to the server collect
responses and then we have struggled i'm
using the apps the output abstraction
function and that we get how we get
sequences of abstract output messages
and then we learn we essentially refine
the state machine that we have so even
with abstraction unfortunately still
doesn't quite work simply because the
computational complexity is too high and
we have pretty high delay message
delaying this in this setting so the
complexities is quadratic in the size of
the input alphabet and then
and also could rotting in the number of
states and linear in the in the size of
counter examples that we construct by
sampling queries so unfortunately
abstraction is is still insufficient so
then studying the the state machines
that we inferred we actually found that
there is a lot of redundancy in the
indole state machines and the primary
cause of redundancy seems to be our
focus on inferring complete state
machines meaning that we want to know
for every input message and for every
state a very transition where the
corresponding transition goes and so it
just happens that many of these messages
don't do anything interesting in most of
the state's you know they do something
interesting only one or two states but
not in all states send up with cases
like this one very have like huge number
of kind of like self loops we just
increase which just increase the cost of
learning without really adding anything
useful to the you know to the inferred
state machine so our idea was to try to
use a prediction and then rely on same
thing to actually take miss predictions
because if you remember you need to do
this you know generate the same thing
queries anyways you know whether you're
doing like same thing basically one's
checking or or black box are bounded
black box model checking you have to
generate these queries anyways so it
might as well use them for checking our
predictions as well and so it turns out
that this prediction that I'm going to
explain it i'm going to actually explain
only the first out of the two prediction
approaches that we use and the first one
actually saves about seventy-three
percent of queries which makes a pretty
big impact on the performance then we
also have some probabilistic prediction
which saves additional thirteen percent
so the the basic idea behind response
prediction is is as follows so in this
state machine for instance we have to
self loops like the red one and the blue
one represented by red and blue state
distinguishing vectors so now you can
see that the response in the upper part
of the table is of course exactly the
same
is in the lower part of the table so now
the question is can we actually use that
insight to predict responses and
therefore save these two like red and
blue to avoid these two queries so the
first insight is here is that if you
look at the s part of the table which is
the upper part then the prefixes are
essentially like you can see them as
strings of messages that are kind of
like shortest sequences that get you to
each individual state so effectively you
can see you can imagine expanding the
state machine into spanning tree and
then these sequences in the upper part
of the table are you know the
essentially labels of parts to each
individual node in the tree because
there are they're free of self loops now
we can try to to use these sequences in
the upper part of the table to predict
responses and that's exactly what we do
so we introduce a restriction function
law which takes sequence of input
messages in the in the original input
alphabet and then a set of messages that
are in this part as part of the table in
particular in this case we would have
only B and C in C to D and then it
essentially removes all the messages
that are not in d for instance if you
have you know if you take this string be
concatenated with a then row of be
concatenated with a is just be because
simply because a is not in D and then
for another let's take another example
into into consideration so for instance
for be concatenated with see then row of
be concatenated sees become constant VDC
and because all the both of these
symbols are in the so there is nothing
to obstruct here so formally this is
what the Rho function does well if the
sequences is is an empty sequence well
that's what it returns otherwise if the
input sequence s is equal to a
concatenated r and a is not
tindie then we recurse on our and
otherwise we copy a to the output and
then recurse on our again so it's it's
fairly simple function so how did how
does this work so let's assume that we
go to this stage in in building the
table so now we have input be
concatenated with a concatenated with a
so we have baa and now if the computer
if you restrict that we turn it turns
out that we get a B from the prefix and
then we can we see that we have already
dead sequence in the upper part of the
table and we can use the whole
distinguishing vector state distinction
vector from dead state to predict the
response and that's what we do and then
repeat the same for the next one
unfortunately here we don't have we
can't reuse any of the previously
generated sequences be the same thing
again and when we get for instance to
see concatenated with a then again a
restriction of that is just see we
already have that row in the upper part
of the table so we just copied the
response and that's it at this point we
are done and then we can use in this
case it happens to in this case actually
the predictions are correct but then
when we miss predict something then we
can use the same thing queries to to
detect that okay so how well does this
work well here I have some results so
for mega d we actually got a huge saving
so from from about 4.5 days to about 12
hours and then if you paralyzed we also
have some paralyzation then you can get
it down to two point four hours however
for smtp protocols we actually didn't
get that much of a saving but there's
actually good explanation behind that
because when we were writing these
abstraction functions for smtp we
already knew how the protocol looks like
and so it was very easy for us to come
up with the right abstraction
so there was very little redundant seen
that abstraction however when you're
working with say proprietary or
classified protocol then you don't
really know how the protocol works or
what is important so you tend to err
more on the side of caution so you kind
of you come up usually with abstractions
that are too precise and in that setting
this prediction actually saves saves a
lot and this is just a high level
architecture of the of our system so we
use L star and then send queries views
response prediction to try to avoid
sending them to the network gives a
whole bunch of both emulators in
parallel but I think eight of them and
these are just scripts that we roll to
kind of like pretend to be both so in
that sense this experiment was Savior
cave careful not to spread the infection
and also there is a limit on actually
how much you can paralyze because the
tour becomes the the bottleneck so after
adding like more than eight emulators in
parallel we essentially started getting
diminishing returns so and then we sent
the queries to tour and we get responses
and it's how the whole thing works so
here we have an example of a protocol
state machine for smtp inferred for
postfix implementation and these red
edges are showed are the edges that the
prior work was not able to infer so this
is the kind of like incremental
improvement of our work upon what was
done in the past so prior work most of
the prior work actually focused on
incomplete state machine inference so
that's that's essentially the reason why
they miss these edges another thing that
you can do once when you have say you
know protocol state machine you can of
course model check it and this is the
state machine for for mega d protocol
and one of the properties for instance
that we checked was whether we can steal
the spam templates from template server
the way it's supposed to work is that
each body is supposed to authenticate
with the master server get
authentication kind of ID and then send
it to the template server in order to
get the templates but and that is that
kind of the red part shows the standard
kind of operation of this protocol
that's there's a part that each body is
supposed to follow but we actually found
plenty of ways to just kind of bypass
authentication just send essentially
random messages to the to the template
server in that way still the templates
and the reason why that is useful is
because you can essentially get
unlimited access to fresh templates and
therefore update spam servers I spend of
filters before the first spam hits the
net and also another thing that you can
do you can use these differences for
fingerprinting for instance mega D has
its own SMTP protocol implementation
which is slightly different from the
post week post weeks smtp so you can use
these differences to kind of detect on
your kind of corporate network you know
that you have an infection I'm going on
and also it's possible we also found
differences between different kind of
implementations of smtp so you can also
distinguish kind of different types of
implementations like post pics from
something else often the malware is
going to be operating on known ports and
so your ear effectively should just
probing reports with these messages to
figure out yes so in this case we knew
the force that it operated on so what
I'm saying that if you if you if you do
this kind of like inference and then
infer a state machine then that state
machine tells you about the differences
between normal traffic and in some cases
of course in this
for sure the well-known correctly
behaving protocols on certain ports and
you're going to do this periodic
learning in the environment and then
compare yeah possibly or you can even
essentially have like stateful firewalls
that are just going to follow each kind
of session and follow it through the
state machine and that way detected
something is is going on okay so with
that I'll move to to the second part of
the talk which essentially is combining
what what I've just presented with with
dart the main idea is to use that a
protocol model depth that we can infer
to actually guide the search what it
actually does is that it combines dart
with learning and just my insight is
that in many ways dart is very similar
to what a decision procedures do the one
big difference is the decision
procedures also get a lot of leverage
from learning a various llamas that
prevent them from making the same
mistakes in the future and so I just
thought that perhaps you know combining
this learning approach in some way with
dart might give us some benefit for
instance for reducing the size of the
search based pruning search space or
just providing more guidance so the
basic idea here is to use the prototype
presented in the first part to infer a
state machine of say you know some
implementation of a protocol say a
server and then use the state machine to
first initialize the search of certain
state so that way you get more control
with a search and then do local
exploration using just under dart
another benefit also is that it
essentially the state machine specifies
the sequence of messages that you need
to get the particular state which is
something that that can be fairly
difficult to construct with its standard
approaches with even the decision
procedure simply because you don't have
enough information to do that so this is
the the maze approach at very high level
of abstraction so we start running some
number of state explorers in parallel on
on the on the server or network
application that you're interested in
and so we generate a whole bunch of
these input and help message a--'s and
as I said before inferring state machine
over all of these messages would be
computationally feasible so we need some
kind of abstraction to reduce or
obstruct these messages and here we have
a filter function that I'm going to
explain later that does exactly that so
it essentially figure out figures out
which input messages to keep and which
to discard it effectively besides what
over which messages is the state machine
going to be learned over and so then we
go to L star R which uses this
monotonically increasing set of input
messages to learn kind of more and more
refined state machines and then we use
just the standard approach that I
present in the first part once when you
get the state machine we generate for
every state the shortest sequence that
essentially tells you how to get to that
state we initialize the state explorers
that state and then we repeat the
process and eventually distinct
terminates because we limit the amount
of time spent per pair each state in the
state exploration phase so you either
don't discover any new messages or you
infer complete state machine and so the
thing terminates in practice we also do
something else we also actually the very
in very first iteration we start with
some set of seed messages to infer the
very first state machine and the reason
for that is just to to speed up the
convergence but strictly speaking it's
not necessary
the classic way
dart is used is you have some input
somalian but like a vial or something
you trying to find different different
inputs to press coverage but but you
really want to use that a subroutine for
testing and really network protocols so
you have an addition to the problem of
finding the inputs sort of you want to
also find the state machine to allow you
to throughout the program to interesting
states because oh yeah so and so I've
been presenting these are so that the
current version of mace so what I'm
presenting is really targets the words
kind of networked applications but i
think that the same idea essentially
applies to say parcels because you could
imagine inferring like context-free
language and then use that to guide
further exploration in a similar way
right no you need to some some way to
curb the response yes you need this
notion of an observable output that
could be used to distinguish internal
states yeah yeah but you can also in
Alice you can essentially use the white
white box model and you can you can
analyze the application at the same time
yeah so the first world that I presented
on own inference of Bolton protocols and
protocols in general really assumed the
completely black box model simply
because we didn't even have access to
the code of these servers we had no
choice so we had to treat it those
service completely black boxes but in
maize we actually do a kind of code
analysis to infer these messages so it's
already kind of a combination of black
box and white box approach so the way it
works it's in a way similar to what they
presented before the difference here is
that we actually used our to generate
messages rather than just observe kind
of random traffic and another difference
here is that now we infer the input
abstraction function we essentially do
this abstraction automatically as I'll
describe on the next slide but we still
require the output abstraction function
to be provided manually simply because
it determines essentially the coarseness
of the state machine that you infer and
therefore you know it's fair
it seems very difficult to automatically
find the right trade of between the the
precision of the state machine and yet
in the computational cost of inferring
very precise state machine so so this is
the filtering function it takes the
current version of the inferred
automaton it takes an input sequence a
sequence of input messages sequence of
all two messages and then produces a set
of input messages that are going to be
used to refine the current abstract
input input alphabet and what it does is
actually fairly simple so it looks at
whether there exists a a part in the
current version of the state machine
that produces the same output as the
current is the output sequence that you
pass through the function so in other
words if there is a way to produce that
sequence of output messages with the
current state machine then you don't add
anything to the input alphabet on the
other hand if you can't produce the same
sequence of all the messages then you
know that there is something at least
one new message and that's that then we
add actually all the messages in the
input sequence to the abstract input
alphabet and then learn another
essentially we repeat learning that the
second iteration of learning is done
over this kind of refined alphabet and
we learn any refined state machine so we
evaluate this on a number of benchmarks
so we inferred the protocol on on V no
implementation of the rfb protocol and
on some implementation of the SMB
protocol so and once when we inferred
these state machines we also use them to
test realvnc and v-necks PS and be
without rain for the protocol and that
of course relies on the assumption that
the protocols are fairly similar because
you can once when you infer the state
machine you can use it for you know for
testing various implementations as long
as the protocols are fairly you know
similar and for vino views the 45 second
session of remote
45 second remote desktop session to
generate the set of seed messages and
for somebody use gent a street for I'd
know how many seconds you ran it just
you know to bootstrap the process if you
rent this on on the dieter security
testbed allocating essentially about 2.5
hours of state exploration per each
discovered state and we did this only
for every only when a new state was
inferred so we wouldn't repeat this for
all the known states for obvious reasons
and also for the coverage measurement
experiments are we made sure that the
baseline which was state-of-the-art dart
engine that the baseline gets exactly
the same amount of time as the maze
approach and that also includes the time
required for that maze required for
learning the protocol so for for vino
when we inferred the protocol in two
iterations after about 150 minutes and
for samba Benford leading about three
iterations and it took us about a bit
over 4000 minutes so this is the SMB
protocol state machine that inferred so
it's about eighty four states I think
it's clear that it would be too much to
ask a programmer to kind of to specify
this perhaps not I don't know but it
looks like completely it looks fairly
difficult to want to infer into to
specify and so this table shows the
vulnerabilities that we found so we
found seven vulnerabilities all together
four of which are new and we got some
silly numbers for them and the for
instance for vino the first one was
inferred about after about one hour ago
exploration in total the second one
after four hours the third one after 15
hours and the baseline a fortune didn't
have the capability to detect the very
first vulnerability because it was an
infinite loop so it's kind of like
denial of service attack
and our baseline implementation dart
implementation didn't have a detector
for infinite loops so it wasn't able to
discover this one in particular but it
had the capability to discover the
remaining two which were wild out of
bound writes reads sorry but even though
it had the capability they actually
failed to discover them even even after
105 hours of exploration and then for
samba we found three vulnerabilities we
actually hadn't known about any of these
when we found them but later we found
that they were already known and the
baseline approach managed to discover
only one of those after about six
hundred and two hours while maze took
only about 12 hours and then for Vince
realvnc we found another one and we
found none for of in XP SMB so this is
this is an interesting graph we wanted
to kind of see how how how deeply does
the baseline approach get into the
search space comparing to mace and so
what we did is that we expanded the
stage machine into a tree and then
measured the percentage of states that
each approach reaches at certain depth
and for me is of course not surprisingly
it can reach any states simply because
it knows the state machine so it's very
easy to construct the sequence that's
going to get you to that state but
what's interesting is that the baseline
approach coverage actually falls very
rapidly and so for instance when you get
to depths of 5 it reaches only about
forty percent of state and then when you
get to depths of eight essentially it
falls down to zero and I believe that
this is the reason why we also got much
better coverage with me so we got
coverage improvements ranging from about
six percent to like fifty-eight percent
depending on the on the benchmark so um
my impression is that the reason why
mace works so well is that by learning a
state machine you effectively use
relatively cheap reasoning to infer a
kind of like high level abstraction of
the program actually
protocol that it implements then you can
use that to guide the search and it's
also very easy to construct sequences
that are going to get it to a certain
state which is something that's
relatively difficult for Ford art to
doing it sounds simply because it
doesn't have enough information and also
another side effect is that you also get
kind of more control over your search
because you kind of like can diversify
your search more easily it's less likely
that you're going to get stuck in in
loops so with that I'll end the the
second part of the talk and I have just
about five minutes to 2 zip over the
malware detection part okay so you know
what is malware I'm going to skip that
so this slide essentially shows the
effectiveness of modern antivirus tools
this is this is study done by Cisco
security team it essentially shows that
on the first day when new malware is
released only about twenty percent
malware is detected by contemporary
antivirus tools and then if they keep
you know cranking out new signatures and
updating you know the signature database
they get to about sixty percent or
something like that after about seven
days but it's a fit only only one of
these samples suffices to actually you
know to really create problems so this
is this is far from from satisfying the
reason why this is so difficult well in
general sources are not available and
binaries are quite often obfuscated it
or even encrypted so it's very frequent
that you can't even disassemble the the
code you can't distinguish what's called
what's what's data and also many of
these tools are automatically detect
that you're in debug mode or that you're
running some antivirus and then it's
difficult to analyze them just to
summarize this smaller crash course so
as I mentioned earlier you know you're
getting around 60,000 samples per day so
the daily volume is just too large for
manual analysis and unfortunately that's
what's being done today many of these
samples are analyzed manually and it
takes about 15 to 2 20 30 minutes
for an experienced analyst actually go
through these samples also the
cumulative volume is too large for
expensive analysis because you know
we're getting about 20 million of these
samples per year and then there is a
huge backlog of malware that you have to
go through also signatures are
unfortunately too easy to defeat as the
previous slide showed and static
analysis frequently very difficult or
impossible and so to address these last
two are issues the security community
has started researching behavioral
detection approaches that really focus
on what software does rather than how it
does it and one popular abstraction of
behavior is essentially a sequence of
system calls because in order to change
the state of the system then the
application has to you know execute a
system call for instance to create a
file or change registry key and so what
you can do is that you can generate kind
of sequences of these system calls and
then use that to kind of recognize
what's potentially malicious what not
what we did was slightly kind of more
complicated we actually use taint
analysis to construct dataflow
dependency graphs of system calls for
instance if one system call you know
generate some result and then later that
result is kind of like change in the
application passed as a parameter is
another system call then we would say
that there is a data flow dependence eh
there and then of course that that from
that relation you can construct a graph
that you can see here this is from a
real world example called a trojan
called banker so now once when you
construct these graphs you can imagine
expanding them into trees that's not
what what we really do because that
would incur an exponential cost but you
can just imagine for that that's how it
works just simplifies the presentation
so you know you can mention expanding
this into trees and then we can
eliminate the graphs that are common in
between malware and good there and then
we end up with reduced set and now we
can use this reduced set in for a state
machine that's going to distinguish
to in the cave paper what I'm actually
doing is slightly simpler than that
because I just use the positive examples
but you know one could use negative
examples as well to get higher precision
so I don't think I'll have time to
actually go into the into three automata
so I'm going to skip the next two slides
okay the main idea is that you have
these trees and then you construct a
window of certain size and then by
zipping that window over the entire tree
and creating the state for every kind of
unique subtree that you see you can
essentially construct the tree automaton
and that's roughly how it works and then
of course the the final the accepting
states are those states that essentially
accept the the whole tree that you've
seen the the k-factor which is the size
of that window is inductive bias and
that helps us to actually do inference
from positive examples but that K factor
is very important because the larger the
smaller decay the more obstruct the
state machines that you infer are going
to be so you can actually very the trade
of trade of between true positives and
false positives by changing this K and
that's something that's very useful in
practice and that is actually due to
Tyrion by Garcia that the language is
determined by a k plus 1 sized window
are kind of contained in languages that
are in the determined by at the K size
window and so the algorithm that I came
up with essentially has almost linear
complexity ver it's k and complexity
where n is the size of the graphs so
it's very efficient in practice and it
certainly can scale to very large
backlog of malware that we have the
overall algorithm works like this so we
collect the graphs we learned ultimate
own and then the partition
test set according to the heights of the
trees and then we run all those graphs
against the tree automaton and then for
each height we compute a score by
computing the ratio of number of
accepted trees with that height with a
total number of trees in that partition
having that height and then we multiply
by the height of the tree because the
idea is that the larger the tree that is
accepted the more weight it should get
and that is the score that that that we
that we compute for malware and then the
hard disk or the more likely it is that
the sample is malicious and then you
know we did experiments on on pretty
large set of malware grouped in
something like forty eight families and
we also use some good where samples on
to to compute the false positive rate so
I'm going to skip this and so these are
the results so the rising curves from
left to right are the malware detection
curves so what the curve means is that
it every point on the curve for every K
we have different case here shows the
percentage of malware that had score
less than what we have on the x-axis so
for instance in this case a 40-percent
of malware had score less than than no
wait about ten percent of malware head
score less than 0.4 the the curves that
fall from left to right are good for
detection curves so they're exactly the
opposite so every point on that curve
says what is the percentage of good
where that head score larger than what
is indicated on the x-axis so for
instance now you can find some sweet
spot I think that one of the sweet spots
was
for instance k equals 4 and the score of
0.6 at this point you would get
something like eighty percent Mulder
recognition rate with about five percent
false positive rate and you can adjust
these as needed and another interesting
result is that you can also use these
inferred tree automata to kind of
classify samples into families if you
learn one automaton their family you
know your distinct you kind of split
these families into like train and test
set and then you learn one automaton
proof for every family and then you run
it against the you run the samples from
the test from old test sets on the
inferred automata and then you can
compute scores and that's what exactly
what I did here and you can see that
there is a fairly pronounced diagonal
here which essentially indicates that
these this approach can be also used at
least partially for classification it
would be nice if if classification like
capability for more pronounced but
that's what they have at the moment and
so to summarize I talked to rich about
grammatical inference and I presented
three possible applications protocol
inference and then also using that for
guiding states-based exploration also
structural feature recognition for
malware detection and I think that many
other applications are possible like
namely synthesis inference of Q
invariance and many others and I'd also
like to make a prediction by my gut
feeling is that in the coming years
perhaps GI I might come might become as
important as in smt simply because it
allows us to do kind of reasoning that
other techniques are not that strong at
and it's very complementary approach
that I think can complement smt and
other approaches that we've been using
so for the future work so one of the
things that I'm looking into is symbolic
maze so how can we do this analysis we'd
say symbolic automata and try to make it
more
of generic and that way also kind of
more perhaps even perhaps you can even
improve performance by going symbolic
rather than having you know to deal with
concrete messages and potentially large
alphabet another possible direction to
go is to try to do the same thing for
context-free grammars because that is
kind of fairly big problem to get past
these parsers in practice and if you can
infer a context-free grammar then you
have you know the structure the state
space and it could help you get past the
parser and also something that I've been
looking into is is regular model
checking of distributed systems and
there you can use grammatical
interesting for the Q invariants and
also to some other things so I'd like to
wrap up with the by acknowledging people
that have been working with me on on a
number of these projects and also the
funding agencies thanks so I thought
that using machine learning for
classification of amber was pretty
standard not sorry not using tree
but can you compare I mean is it true
expert in second and I have watched the
key strength you see learning tree
automata these type of abstraction vs
maybe statistical what I believe which
are being used justification so that's a
that's a great question um so there was
a there are few papers on on using
machine learning like I think feature
identification and leap analysis or
something like that if I remember
correctly for malware detection and they
got relatively similar results but their
implementation as far as I know is not
publicly available so we're not able to
do like a direct comparison although we
use very similar or essentially the same
set of malware samples for benchmarking
other than that most of the mainstream
antivirus tools as far as I know
actually use the signature based
approach and also detect some behaviors
but they're kind of like less systematic
about it but I think yeah potentially
statistical approaches might be useful
for detecting these behaviors as well
and actually I have one collaboration
with some people from rice where we have
started looking into this a little bit I
don't know what was going to come out of
that
the most general atomics on for some set
of inputs is understandable
well it depends in depends on a lot of
factors it depends on the language that
you want to learn it depends on whether
you have only positive examples whether
we have negative examples as well it
depends on whether it's a passive or
active it depends on whether you want to
learn a minimal otamatone or not so the
dancer if you can specify your question
is little bit more perhaps I can give
you more precise answer in inference of
new models for program and so on so
there it seems like the general idea
at some point in
let's just learn a bee pairs because
learning a ton of a smart so there I
guess the question was committed the
most general minimal comic-con for a
given set of given sort of chases so
you're essentially talking about passive
inference from observed set of traces if
you want to learn a finite state machine
that's minimal I believe that's NP
complete but you need to have negative
examples as well so i'm assuming that
you have both positive and negative
samples do you have a negative samples
as well i just have sequins is among the
most general examined all the characters
well that's well the most general
automaton is just a single state
automaton so that's kind of like little
bit under specified still but there are
algorithms that are like rpn I that
learn from positive and negative sets
that are kind of polynomial if you want
to learn only from positive sets then
approach is like you know based on k
testable automata might be a good way to
go I don't know I would need to learn
more details about the problem that you
have
so like this thing's an abstraction
guide distinct so I besides paper smash
also in which he was making these
abstractions what testing for those
abstractions of so are you saying that
races are different way of constructing
those abstractions in which you can just
do better testing of the things so
should I look at me as that way that you
also have an abstraction along with your
testing frameworks rescue explained on
community yeah so on all right the way I
see it is essentially it really is kind
of a particular type of learning
combined with with dart so you
essentially do this state space
exploration the same way as dart does
just you're trying to use them from the
information whatever you discover during
that exploration takes you learn
something about the state space and then
use that knowledge to drive further
search later down the line and you know
this is just one way of you know they're
probably many many possible ways to
learn something from there's a lot of
information that's kind of currently
being discarded from from dart and you
know I guess that you could come up with
many many different approaches to learn
this is just one kind of like simple
point in the so Tommy had a question
right so you could you could look at it
as as this learning summaries of some
sort I mean generally
you can learn summaries of procedures
but you can also learn a summary of the
whole program so your state machine is a
summary of the input help of the
indicative of the program and those
summaries you learn at that level you
can also learn them if you were able to
observe sort of the internal output
input output relations of functions as
well running right the mall that you
don't hear at luck oppositional and
server easier learned behavior or
medieval components compositional study
program places why here you learn a
monolithic basically state machine which
is not the Yak nicole's damage or you do
not grow and for each procedure
community etc but would be interesting
to see how I mean to learn the actual
abstractions for us that we mix the
abstraction of the system of your test
but otherwise you're going to have to
pay their price
yours decided to fall off structure good
but I guess in case is a network
protocol you have a small set of output
states is that what helps you well how
do you observe like in your maze what
dudes are listing off again you have
some abstraction for the input put 16
men and your output your output alpha if
it's fixed in advance not only the
abstraction function is yeah oh so Delta
is also part of the best friend that
determines what state machine you learn
yes sir all right now yes so that's
that's why we essentially it was very
difficult we we didn't actually succeed
that doing this output abstraction
automatically as well exactly because
the state machine that you infer is so
sensitive to this output abstraction you
get like widely you know a very wide
kind of range of state machines
depending even with you know even after
doing kind of very small tweaks to the
abstraction function so yeah but the
girl returned like an error could just
be a useful person
but you sent a packet he gets one of 10
error codes maybe a packet not
recognized illegals illegal states are
for this message or may hope hopefully
there would be like but a small set I
don't know was that of a bear so you
could use the error codes as I mean
presumably there would be some yeah it
was interesting for for some by
inference it was that there are so many
error codes that if you want to handle
all of them if you want to represent all
of them in your alphabet then the
inference blows up so we actually
attracted many of these error responses
into the same equivalence class we just
carry there was an error or not but yeah
if you could come up with some kind of
more modular way or automatically to
obstruct these or even to kind of infer
a symbolic state machines where you know
that would take care out of you know a
lot of these issues that are essentially
all due to the size of the alphabet okay
thanks again